The Joe Rogan Experience my rap career
is a total different world than what
this is of course my rep Corral will say
what made that bet is that I I started a
little too old
so I didn't really get recognition or
you know
until I was 30 years old
and you gotta think I've been trying to
do this my entire 20s so when I started
to be a rapper or get recognition for it
and being that I had a bitter attitude
towards it you know what I'm saying
because it takes so long for it to
happen that happens and then now I'm I'm
30 years old it's a 30 year old rapper
is like how the the it's like a ticking
time bomb at that point like how much
time you got really so I'm already in my
head like I will say a lot of people say
like being a rapper is dangerous like
you know because all the killings and
[ __ ] like but I would say being a rapper
is dangerous in the sense because
once you do it you can't do nothing else
it ruins you so let's just say okay
let's just say I I was a rapper and then
it failed then I got to go get a normal
job well if anybody but I have minimum
success you saw my video somewhere I had
a couple of you and now I'm working at a
job with you now you're like oh you
blah blah yeah so that and Everywhere
You Go somebody
oh that's true so you always recognize
but that's true so you're always getting
acknowledged for your failures but
that's true every time so just imagine
every time someone recognizes you
they're acknowledging your failure
that hurts
it hurts of course it does
but that's what happens in all walks of
life anytime when you fail and people
get to [ __ ] on you and if you're
publicly if you work fries at McDonald's
no one cares don't you remember Gary
Coleman [ __ ] Gary there's no Different
Strokes all right he started working as
a security guard and people would just
[ __ ] on him relentlessly and like
imagine that because if he was just a
security guard no one would care you
would never walk up to a security guard
and go look at this [ __ ] loser you're
a security guard that's exactly what I'm
saying so it's the same thing with
actors so me being Danny Brown I can't
never go back to being I can never go
back to being Daniel Danny you don't
have to first of all and don't and don't
even don't even think about it you don't
have to you're never gonna have to do
that I know what you're saying but you
you can't think about like worst case
scenario and and dwell on it like that
you are of personality and the
personality can do anything it wants to
do you're a fun guy I think about that
and uh and I love that too because you
got to think the last album I put out
was 2019.
yeah you were saying that and that was
um you're tore them infrequently no I
worked on that album with Q-Tip from you
know just to be able to work with Q-Tip
which is such a [ __ ] big deal to me
for sure I mean you know it it gave me
confidence in my music
to be in the fact that A Tribe Called
Quest was my dad's favorite rap group I
remember going to my dad taking me to
[ __ ] preschool I mean I'm preschool
it wasn't that early but whatever
whatever but Elementary School my dad
taking me to school and he's Listening
to A Tribe Called Quest
and before I know it one day I'm sitting
in the studio with Q-Tip every day
working on the app so it was [ __ ] it
was a big deal you know what I'm saying
it was a big deal for me and
you know we made that album and
I guess think um the word of Music have
changed so much we're like um
a 10 second Tick Tock beat
means way more than you putting out a
single
hmm you understand what I'm saying yeah
like that whole
[ __ ] change so the way I grew up the way
I grew up like me my favorite rapper is
Nas
and now she put a new album and that
album is [ __ ] amazing and you know
why that album is amazing it's because
Nas is having [ __ ] fun and I was able
to make music without any [ __ ] you
gotta think what does is really rich
like he's got a bunch of it wasn't
always like that though no but I'm
saying like right now if he's doing rap
right now it's because he wants to do it
yes but it wasn't always like that he
had the whole situation of what he went
through with his divorces yeah yeah it's
all public yes he's the best Lyricist
ever in my opinion he's his [ __ ] [ __ ]
is so complicated the way he does things
back what's that one song where he does
backwards rewind
that's a brilliant song You Wanna head
is coming bro we don't want to talk
about this all right just for me so nice
and I've had the opportunity to meet
knives a lot like I always say a lot but
he knows
what he means to me you hear what I'm
saying yes so
actually he's um he wanted to sign me to
his label
I didn't sign him to him because
I mean whatever
I mean money man money money man the the
other contract was more money man and
that's what it is but sometimes I think
about that did not make a mistake but
like damn just because
the artist that I looked up to my entire
life that made me be a rapper tried to
sign me and I didn't sign with them all
because of money
um
you know but even we no I'm not saying
like
I feel any way about being with work
like I love work work is you know
they've done part two warp has made me a
better artist than what I actually am
how's that
because like okay just even um like the
album that I just I made the album
um doing covet obviously we were sitting
around when nobody could do nothing and
I just felt like oh [ __ ] I ain't so I
just started going to the studio and
just started recording songs making
music record the album
and this is the album that we're gonna
release but the album been done for like
three years
you know and
what's been the hold up
you don't know
so so on them that's what happened when
you sign the record labels oh Jesus bro
you weren't here bro all right you wanna
hear all right let me give you my
rundown Story I mean three years how
many years I think you need another
drink
I might need another drink yeah all
right so check this out
Danny Brown
being a regular rapper from Detroit
whatever [ __ ] all right whatever sir
thank you cheers
I'm even gonna go into Tony Yayo and G
on it Oh weird [ __ ] just get to the
point of so um
I remember being it's a um
Festival in New York at the time was
called cmj Festival
which was like cool it's like you know
same thing as South by Southwest what is
the Texas that's what it was for New
York they had this Festival cmj festival
and at one of these shows they had um
a Brooklyn Bowl Fool's Gold Records
through a show
and
Kanye showed up
and it shut the whole [ __ ] down like and
I couldn't go I couldn't get in I was
like and to me I was like man fools go
records like man they like the hell this
[ __ ] like if I could ever be cool with
Fool's Gold Records like uh whatever I
can do to be down before we go records I
would do you know what I'm saying type
of [ __ ]
so then [ __ ] goes on years
I end up getting a situation
I started talking to Fool's go
and um
I don't think they were really into
signing me at the time but Q-tip from A
Tribe Called Quest was real close with
aatrac who's one of the owners of fool's
gold and um they hung out and um
a track was like man we thinking about
signing Danny Brown
and Q-Tip was like [ __ ] thinking
are you [ __ ] like this is one of the
Endless things he broke it down to him
like what makes me so ill which I can we
can talk about that has to be nice no
I'm literally like superhero like when
it comes to like rap like it's just like
cheating like I'm like steroid like it's
stupid like I can cheat like it's
superhero so so then so then he was like
[ __ ] it yeah I'm gonna sign it cuz
so then I already knew I was gonna get
signed the fools go we already had this
to each other so it's no negotiation on
what
the city was so I was going to
interviews already like I would do
interviewing they'd be like what's going
to happen and I'd be like Oh I'm
starting the fools go so bum to say that
we we signed a contract I signed for
five thousand dollars
literally five thousand dollars and it
was South by Southwest happened in the
next week
and I had like two shows or something so
I literally spent the entire signing
bonus at South by Southwest the next
week so I had no money super broke
whatever the [ __ ] I'm living off my girl
you know what I'm saying like her
banking on me making it as a rapper
kind of situation you know what I'm
saying yeah we do whatever we do
we get that but then the album comes up
and at the time no one really thought
about the album I would think no one I
did
but at that time no one thought this
album would be like a
a big deal
end up the album come out at one [ __ ]
album of the year and spin a magazine it
ended up being one of the best albums I
ever had in my career like but when you
think about it's like a person back
against the wall
when you listen to the album my back
then so um right this is and the whole
concept of the album is
um you know rap music is all about being
young
20 year olds so I'm the album is called
30. this is an album about a 30 year old
rapper
just now starting to get a break
and how he feels
you know yeah so yeah and
I'm good it did good
it did good it did good I'm saying that
like sales wise or anything like that
but culturally it did good and it got
recognition so I was able to get a lot
of [ __ ] from that and you know I got a
lot of deals and
did my next album after that was old
it's called and but that chart at
billboard but it was a lot of money like
I spent like it was a lot of money spent
in that I say that to say this okay
as me as
a
kid
from Detroit got good at rap all right I
know how to rap a record label signs me
I rap for this record label make an
album
in my head
as when you start to make music you want
to be as experimental and
to be you as much as point you don't
understand is the thing called music
business so you're not think about
business you're just thinking about art
I'm just trying to make the best me
Illmatic was the greatest I've ever
heard in my life
so to me it's like Illmatic and the
other one is cannibalized covain like so
to me it's like I'm trying to make
albums
to mirror those I'm just trying to like
as me as a rapper as an artist or a
musician she's trying to like [ __ ] that
I was influenced about like try to make
a piece of art that could stand next to
that
you know what I'm saying but yeah at
this point in life not that [ __ ] don't
matter no more
because it's too much money to be made
behind this [ __ ]
you hear what I'm saying so
I didn't care about this [ __ ] and then
now
so do you think that by trying to make
something that stands next to that
somehow or another you'll lose money
definitely how come because time change
time changes how the [ __ ] that we liked
in 1994 we don't like it in 2004 I still
do I think yeah we gotta think about the
kids dude I still listen to cool G Rap
Have you listened to Playboy cardi no
see well I'll listen to anything Playboy
card you know everything bro Playboy
cardi can shut down this whole [ __ ]
can we play some of it can we play some
of it we can play you probably what
which uh no no no why
just some
see look I'm gonna be a hater Now by
saying no but no
no
we're not gonna play no Playbook why
because this is my Joe Rogan interview
okay let me know about the [ __ ] yeah
it's not gonna hurt you if he gets a
little love all right you just gave him
some Playboy cardi does not need no love
I'll tell you we'll play that we'll play
a little that just to educate me and
educate the people who listen and then
we'll play
no give me a Danny Brown track that you
like I definitely don't want to hear
your mind after this play playboi carti
stop breathing bro you don't get it I
don't get it help me out my music is
like standard comedy in that sense oh
you want to hear some of my uh stand up
comedy rap sure we'll do that we'll do
that
[ __ ] only thing you gotta know my dick
touched the ground when I'm sitting on
the floor see that's the thing about rap
like
um
you know me I was into comedy and so I
took my whole [ __ ] from Comedy do I were
wrapped so what I would do I would just
sit around and write punch lines all the
time
so I write punch lines so think about
this look I'm about to give y'all [ __ ]
the game so it's 16 bars a verse
is four punch it's four lines for a
verse so let's just say if I sit around
I listen to a Joe Rogan episode someone
says ill punchline on there Uncle Joey
he might say some crazy [ __ ]
you get what I'm saying just some crazy
[ __ ] a line just one line I can take
that one line
four is 16 bars so one line could create
four bars
so every line I get four bars so I need
four lines to give me a 16.
no